Hey, Darren here with Engadget.
We're at Toshiba's booth at SID 2011...
...taking a look at their new mobile display.
This has 367 PPI.
It's obviously a true 720 display here.
This is a four - inch panel...
...and we have been told it will show up in at least one phone later this year,...
...so it will be in the market.
The viewing angles are a little bit worse than a Nexus phone here.
But obviously the resolution is pretty incredible.
Obviously a good panel to get if you would be watching a lot of movies or images here.
As for touch enablement, we're told that's up to the partners...
...so we can pretty much bet that whoever takes this on is gonna put a touchscreen on top of it.
So we couldn't pry out who exactly is gonna be using this...
...but it will be in the market later this year.
So you'll be able to get a 720p display on your future phone.
So, yeah, the retina display has got a little catching up to do.